Плакати і білборди - важлива частина
будь-якої передвиборної агітації
За сім тижнів до виборів у Бундестаг вони з'явилися
й на вулицях Німеччини
Чим цього разу спокушатимуть виборців
основні претенденти на крісла в Бундестазі?
На плакатах правлячого Християнсько-демократичного союзу
чорно-червоно-жовта символіка - у стилі німецького стягу
Єдине обличчя, на яке зробили ставку в ХДС - Анґела Меркель
Цього разу без її родзинки
характерно складених рук
Сповідувані християнськими демократами консервативні цінності
"безпека і порядок"
"сильна економіка і стабільні робочі місця"
а також "повага до родини"
Усе це уособлюють звичайні німці
На 22 тисячі великих і малих плакатів
партія витратила 20 мільйонів євро
"Час модернізуватися", "майбутньому потрібні нові ідеї"
промовляє з плакатів Соціал-демократичної партії її лідер Мартін Шульц
Утім, суперник Меркель також робить ставку
на консервативні цінності - стабільну роботу
турботу про дітей і пенсіонерів, справедливі податки та якісну освіту
Плакатна кампанія обійшлася партії у 24 мільйони євро
Німецькі ЗМІ вже охрестили білборд-кампанію Вільних демократів
рекламою костюмів Hugo Boss
На всіх плакатах - лідер партії Крістіан Лінднер
У білій сорочці, з триденною щетиною
"Думаймо по-новому!" - закликає політик.
На піар Лінднера партія витратила 5 мільйонів євро.
Зелені закинули вільним демократам беззмістовність їхніх плакатів
свою кампанію зробили безособовою
На їхніх плакатах - яскраво рожева земля
і жовтий сонях - на зеленому тлі
Різняться лише цитати
Слоган такий строкатих плакатів - "Тому зелені"
Права "Альтернатива для Німеччини" зробила ставку на скандал
Спочатку за партію мала агітувати одна з лідерів
Фрауке Петрі - із місячним сином на руках
Та після обвинувачень у зловживанні світлинами з немовлям
АдН від такого мотиву відмовилася
Тепер цінності партії презентують оголені дівчата в бікіні
на протиставлення мусульманкам у буркіні
Або свині - як символ того, що "іслам чужий Німеччині"
Кампанію "Лівих" німецькі ЗМІ обізвали найнуднішою
Під гаслом "Жодного бажання, щоб так було й далі"
"ліві" обстюють доступну вартість житла
гідні пенсії та заборону експорту зброї